This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In April 2017, a woman hurried to step off a subway train in the Bronx just as the doors were closing. New Yorkers pull off such near escapes every day, but this passenger was not so lucky. The subway doors pinned her in place, half in, half out of the car. What happened next was deeply unnerving. It wasn't that the subway train started moving. With one of its doors partially open, the train was not going to leave the station.
这里是 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。2017 年 4 月，就在地铁车门即将关上之际，布朗克斯区的一名女子急忙跑下地铁。纽约人每天都会上演这种千钧一发的险情，但这位乘客就没有那么幸运了。地铁车门将她夹在原地，身体一半在车厢内，一半在车厢外。接下来发生的事情让人感到极度不安。并不是说地铁列车开始行驶了。由于有一扇车门半开着，列车是不会离开车站的。
No, the shocking thing, visible in a cell phone video recorded at the scene, was the sight of people walking past the trapped woman. The woman was walking off the train when the doors closed on her. And no one walking by seems to notice or care. Instead of helping, one witness recorded it. Once the video went viral, horrified reactions poured in. Like how could somebody just pass by that? People just caught in their own head.
不，最令人震惊的是，现场拍摄的一段手机视频显示，人们从这名被困女子身边走过。这名女子在车门关上时正要下车。而路过的人似乎都没有注意到，也不在乎。不仅没有人帮忙，反而有一个目击者把这记录了下来。这段视频在网上疯传后，人们震惊的反应如潮水般涌来。比如，怎么会有人就这么无视那一幕？人们只是陷入了自己的思绪中。
They want to do their own thing. Like, you know, I don't have time, you know. What does that say about New Yorkers? I would be flailing and freaking out. In time, a subway employee got the doors open, released the woman, and allowed her to go on her way. But for those who saw evidence of her lonely plight, a question lingered.
他们只想做自己的事。比如，你知道的，我没时间，你知道的。这说明了纽约人什么？我肯定会大喊大叫、惊慌失措。过了一会儿，一名地铁员工把门打开，放出了这名女子，让她继续赶路。但是，对于那些目睹了她孤立无援的困境的人来说，一个疑问久久挥之不去。
A person is suffering, clearly in need of help, and those who see her simply walk by. Is this what we can expect from human nature? Callous indifference and heartlessness? Or is there more to the story? This week on Hidden Brain, the science of altruism. Why some human beings perform acts of extraordinary selflessness, and how the rest of us can learn to be more like them.
一个人正在受苦，明显需要帮助，而看到她的人却径直走过。这就是我们对人性的期望吗？冷酷的漠然和铁石心肠？还是说这背后还有更多隐情？本期的 Hidden Brain 将探讨利他主义的科学。为什么有些人类会做出极其无私的举动，以及我们其他人如何才能学会更像他们。
No matter who we are, no matter how physically strong we may be, and no matter how many resources we have, all of us will need the help of others at some point. In the hour of crisis, will someone extend a hand? Abigail Marsh is a psychologist and neuroscientist at Georgetown University. She has long been interested in why people help one another and also why they don't. Abby Marsh, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Abby, 30 years ago you were a college student. You were driving on Interstate 5 to Tacoma after meeting a friend in Seattle. It was around midnight. I understand this was an extremely busy freeway? Yes, it's
无论我们是谁，无论我们的身体有多强壮，无论我们拥有多少资源，我们所有人在某个时刻都会需要别人的帮助。在危机时刻，会有人伸出援手吗？阿比盖尔·马什 (Abigail Marsh) 是乔治城大学的心理学家和神经科学家。长期以来，她一直对人们为什么会互帮互助以及为什么不这样做感兴趣。阿比·马什，欢迎来到 Hidden Brain。谢谢邀请我。阿比，30 年代前你还是个大学生。你在西雅图见完朋友后，正开车沿着 5 号州际公路前往塔科马。那时大约是午夜。据我所知，这是一条非常繁忙的高速公路？是的，它是
incredibly busy freeway, very heavily trafficked. I was coming into Tacoma on I-5 South from Seattle when the freeway rises up over an overpass and so there are no shoulders whatsoever. And yet somehow a dog had made it onto the freeway that night and it ran across the freeway right in front of my car. And I did what I now know you should never do, which is I swerved to try to avoid it. And unfortunately, I hit it anyways. And the combination of hitting the dog and swerving sharply sent
一条极其繁忙的高速公路，车流量非常大。我当时正从西雅图经由 I-5 南下前往塔科马，当高速公路升高穿过一座立交桥时，那里完全没有路肩。然而不知怎的，那天晚上有一只狗上了高速公路，它就在我的车前跑过了高速公路。我做了我现在知道绝对不应该做的事，那就是猛打方向盘试图避开它。不幸的是，我还是撞到了它。撞到狗和急打方向盘的组合使得
my car into a series of fish tails across several lanes of freeway. It's a miracle I didn't hit anybody. And then it ended up, as I tried to wrestle back control of the car, spinning in these huge donuts around and around until finally it came to a rest in the fast lane of the freeway facing backward into the oncoming traffic just past the crest of the overpass. So your car is now sitting on the highway facing in the wrong direction in the fast lane? In the fast lane and the engine had died as a result of all of this spinning around and
我的车在高速公路的几个车道上连续甩尾。我没有撞到任何人，这真是个奇迹。然后，当我试图重新夺回对汽车的控制时，它开始一圈又一圈地原地打转，最后停在了高速公路的快车道上，车头背向迎面而来的车流，刚好停在立交桥的顶部。所以你的车现在停在高速公路上，车头方向反了，还停在快车道上？在快车道上，而且因为这一连串的旋转，发动机熄火了，而且
there's no shoulder because it's an overpass that didn't have any ends. So there was nowhere I could drive the car to or that I could jump out of the car and run to. I was just stuck in this fast lane of the freeway with cars barely swerving in time to avoid me because they just caught sight of me as they were coming across the crest of the overpass.
没有路肩，因为这是一座没有尽头的高速立交桥。所以我无处开车，也无法跳出车去跑步。我只能被困在高速公路的快车道上，汽车来不及及时转向来避开我，因为它们刚越过立交桥顶就看到了我。
And so my car would shake every time these big cars and semis would swerve around it at the last minute and I knew I just knew it was a matter of time until one of them was going to hit me. Well this is absolutely terrifying Abby and you had no way of moving the car you had no way of getting out of the car, the car wouldn't start. You must have thought these were your last moments. I did. I did. It was the most terrified I've ever been in my life and I remember trying over and over to turn the car back on and I couldn't figure out why I couldn't get the engine to reengage. I remember turning on the
所以每当这些大车和半挂车在最后一分钟绕过它时，我的车就会摇晃，我知道，我心里清楚，其中一辆车撞上我只是时间问题。这绝对太可怕了，阿比，而且你当时无法移动汽车，无法下车，汽车也无法启动。你当时一定觉得这是你最后的时刻了。确实是的。那是我一生中最害怕的一次，我记得一遍又一遍地试图重新启动汽车，却不明白为什么引擎无法重新接合。我记得我打开了
brights, I turned on the flashers just to try to alert people to my presence, but I didn't have a phone because it was the 90s and so there was absolutely nothing else I could do and I thought that eventually I was going to get hit and I would either get very badly hurt or killed. So while this is happening, cars are coming by you at great velocity and swerving and missing you at the very last second. Something happens now on the other side of your car, on the passenger side. Tell me what happens.
远光灯，我打开了双闪灯，只是想提醒人们我的存在，但我当时没有手机，因为那是 90 年代，所以我绝对无能为力，我以为我最终会被撞到，要么受重伤，要么丧命。就在这时，汽车以极高的速度从你身旁驶过，在最后一秒急转弯避开了你。此时，在你的车另一侧，也就是副驾驶一侧，发生了一些事情。告诉我发生了什么。
Yeah, one of the great shocks of my life. So it was a summer night and the windows were rolled down. And I was very surprised in the middle of all this to hear a knock on the passenger side window, which because of which way I was facing was on the very narrow sort of tiny ridge on the edge of the fast lane. And I turned to see a man standing outside the car wearing as best as I can recollect a suit. And he had a shaved head and chains around his neck, gold jewelry and sunglasses, even though it was the middle of the night.
是的，这是我一生中受到的最大震撼之一。那是夏天的夜晚，车窗摇了下来。在这一切混乱之中，我非常惊讶地听到有人敲副驾驶侧的车窗，由于我当时面向的方向，车窗正对着快车道边缘非常狭窄、可以说是微不足道的一道山脊。我转过身去，看到一个男人站在车外，据我记忆所能恢复的，他穿着一套西装。他光着头，脖子上戴着链子，戴着黄金首饰和太阳镜，尽管当时已经是半夜。
Abby had a lot to be worried about in that moment. But the first thought that leaped to her mind was about the stranger's intentions. He asked if she needed help. And I remember the silly thought flashing through my head of like, oh no, oh no, you know, this is a stranger, I'm not supposed to let strangers into my mom's car. And he said, you look like you could use some help. It was quite an understatement.
阿比在那一刻有很多需要担忧的事。但她脑子里闪过的第一个念头却是关于这个陌生人的意图。他问她是否需要帮助。我记得脑子里闪过一个傻乎乎的念头：“哦不，哦不，你知道的，这是个陌生人，我妈妈不让我让陌生人上车。”他说：“你看起来需要帮忙。”这可真是个轻描淡写的说法。
And of course I said, yeah, I do. What did he say? What did he advise you to do? So then he said, okay, do you mind if I get into the driver's seat? So I said, okay, that's fine. And I scooched myself over the center console into the passenger seat while he waited for a break in the traffic, which took a minute, because of course they all were, you know, talking to each other, the cars are still continuing to blow by. So he waited for a break, ran around the car at top speed, opened the driver's door and
我当然回答说：“是的，我需要。”他说什么了？他建议你做什么？然后他说：“好吧，你介意我坐到驾驶座上吗？”我说：“好吧，可以。”我顺着中控台挪到了副驾驶座上，而他则等待车流出现空隙，这花了一分钟时间，因为当然了，它们都还在，你知道的，互相交谈着，车辆仍然在飞驰而过。所以他等了一个空隙，以最快的速度绕到车前，打开驾驶室的门，
hopped in the driver's seat. So now he's put himself in great danger because now we're both going to get killed if we get hit. He figured out the car was still in drive, which is why I couldn't get it to turn back on, put it in park, turn it back on, waited again for a break and all the cars blowing by us. And then he gunned it real fast and arced us across the freeway into the off ramp on the other side of the sort of stripey section by the off right where his car was parked. And there we came to a stop. And we were more or less safe at that point. And again, I remember the sound of his voice as he looked at me.
跳进了驾驶座。现在他把自己置于极大的危险之中，因为如果我们被撞，我们两个都会丧命。他发现车仍然挂在 D 挡（前进挡），这就是为什么我无法重新启动它，他把它挂入 P 挡（驻车挡），重新启动了车，再次等待车流出现空隙，周围所有的车都在飞驰而过。然后他猛踩油门，将车成弧线开过高速公路，驶向右侧出口附近有条纹区域的另一侧匝道——他的车就停在那里。我们在那里停了下来。我们在那个时候或多或少安全了。再次，我记得他看着我时他的声音，
I'm gray, I'm sure, and sweaty and shaking. I felt awful. And he said, are you going to be okay? Do you need me to follow you home? And I said, no, no, I'm gonna be okay, I'll be okay. You know, I wasn't thinking quite straight in the moment. And he said, okay, you take care of yourself. And out of the car he got and went back to his own car and drove off into the night. And that is the last I ever saw of him.
我敢肯定我当时面色惨白、满头大汗而且浑身发抖。我感觉糟糕透了。他说：“你没事吧？需要我跟着你回家吗？”我说：“不，不，我会没事的，我会没事的。”你知道，我当时脑子转得不太清楚。他说：“好吧，保重。”然后他下车，回到了他自己的车里，驶入了夜色中。那是我最后一次见到他。
["The Last Supper"] Did you even get to thank him, Abby? It is one of the things that eats at me to this day that I don't think I said thank you. And I didn't get his name, so I'll never be able to thank him. So I'm wondering, Abby, did you ever figure out how he came to be standing by the passenger side window of your car? How did he get there? It's a great question. I only figured it out later.
[“最后的晚餐”] 阿比，你甚至都没来得及向他道谢吗？这件事至今仍在我心里挥之不去，我觉得自己当时没有说谢谢。而且我连他的名字都不知道，所以我再也无法向他道谢了。所以我想知道，阿比，你后来有没有弄清楚他是怎么来到你的车副驾驶侧窗户旁的？他是怎么过去的？这是一个很好的问题。我后来才想明白。
And what I realized is that he must have been among all of those cars that came across the crest of the freeway and saw my stranded car there. He was the one that decided in the fraction of a second he had to make a decision to pull over into the off-ramp area and then run across six lanes of freeway traffic in the middle of the night to get to my car. So he pulls off the freeway, gets out of his car, runs across the freeway, middle of the night, comes to your side, gets you to move over to the passenger side, risks his life again getting into traffic to get into the driver's seat, finds a way to turn on the car, again waits for a break in the traffic, risks his own
我意识到，他一定也在那些翻过高速公路顶峰、看到我搁浅在那里的汽车的所有车辆之中。他是那个在决定靠边停在匝道区域时只有短短几分之一秒可以做决定的人，然后他在半夜冒着危险跑过六车道的高速公路车流来到我的车旁。所以他把车开下高速公路，下车，穿过高速公路，在半夜来到你这一侧，让你挪到副驾驶座上，再次冒着生命危险冲进车流坐上驾驶位，想方设法发动汽车，再次等待车流出现空隙，冒着生命
life to pull the car around to safety. I mean, he risked his life three times that night for you. He did. He did indeed. I'm wondering how this left you feeling in the days and weeks that followed, Abby. Well, in the immediate aftermath, I was so shaken up that my mom could tell when I woke up the next morning something terrible had happened. I was in a little bit of shock, I think. Dog lover that I am, I was horrified that I had killed a dog. That really ate at me for a long time. But more than that, I was in real shock over how close
危险把车开到安全地带。我的意思是，那天晚上他为了你冒了三次生命危险。他确实这么做了。确实如此。阿比，我想知道这让你在接下来的几天和几周里有何感想。嗯，在事情发生后的第一时间，我受到的惊吓太大了，以至于我妈妈第二天早上醒来时就能看出发生了什么可怕的事情。我想我当时有点休克。作为一个爱狗人士，我为自己撞死了一只狗感到惊恐万分。那件事确实折磨了我很久。但不仅如此，我真正震惊的是，自己离死亡
I had come to dying, closer than I have ever come before since. And that dissipated over time, as it does. What didn't dissipate is this worm in my brain that I sort of felt at the idea that the reason I had died or been terribly injured was because of the decisions of this man. And struggling to understand what caused him to make the choice that he did, to endanger his life multiple times so seriously, to help a person he'd never met and whose identity
竟然如此之近，比我以前或之后经历过的任何一次都要近。随着时间推移，这种感觉消散了，就像通常那样。没有消散的是我脑子里的一根刺，我有一种感觉，那就是我之所以死里逃生或没有受重伤，全是因为这个男人的决定。我努力去理解是什么驱使他做出那样的选择，为了帮助一个素不相识、甚至在做出帮助决定时
he could not possibly have known when he made the choice to help me. Could you have imagined doing this for someone else if the tables had been turned, Abby? That's a hard question to answer. I have never been put in exactly that situation, but I've never done anything so dangerous to help a stranger, certainly not. No, I think it's a very, very rare decision to make and I have never made it. So you're still in college at this time.
根本不可能知道她身份的人，竟然数次置自己的生命于不顾。阿比，如果角色互换，你能想象自己会为别人这样做吗？这是一个很难回答的问题。我从未经历过那种确切的情况，但我从未为了帮助一个陌生人做过如此危险的事情，当然没有。不，我认为这是一个非常非常罕见的决定，而我从未做出过这样的决定。所以你当时还在上大学。
I'm wondering whether the experience changed the course of your college career and what you thought you wanted to study. In retrospect, absolutely. I had already taken a course in psychology and had fallen in love with the idea that there is a science of human cognition and behavior. But what very quickly happened after that is I started thinking about the psychology of why people help other people, why on earth somebody would make the decision
我想知道这段经历是否改变了你大学生涯的方向以及你想研究的领域。回想起来，绝对改变了。我当时已经选修了一门心理学课程，并爱上了这样一种理念，即存在一门关于人类认知和行为的科学。但在此之后不久，很快发生的事情是，我开始思考人类为什么会帮助他人的心理学，为什么有人会做出这样的决定：
to risk their own life to help another person. And very quickly my research took a turn toward that specific topic. We often assume that people are fundamentally self-interested, that everyone is out for themselves. How then to explain the fact that some people help others at great cost to themselves without any expectation of recognition or reward? When we come back, the psychology of selflessness.
冒着自己的生命危险去帮助另一个人。很快，我的研究方向就转向了这个特定的主题。我们经常假设人类本质上是自私的，每个人都在为自己打算。那么，该如何解释这样一个事实：有些人不惜付出巨大代价去帮助他人，却没有任何获得认可或回报的预期？当我们回来时，将探讨无私的心理学。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At Georgetown University, psychologist Abigail Marsh studies why some people are given to great acts of selfless generosity. Her interest was spurred by a dramatic moment in her own life when a stranger rescued her after her car spun out of control on a busy freeway. Abby never learned the stranger's name but she realized afterwards that he had risked his life multiple times in order to save hers. Abby, after your encounter with this extraordinary altruist, you became a psychologist and you became interested in altruism writ large. Now, that includes people who engage in these kinds of heroic rescues,
你正在收听的是 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。这里是 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。在乔治城大学，心理学家阿比盖尔·马什 (Abigail Marsh) 致力于研究为什么有些人会有巨大的无私奉献行为。她的兴趣源于她自己生活中的一个戏剧性时刻，当时她的汽车在一处繁忙的高速公路上失控打转后，一个陌生人救了她。阿比从未得知这个陌生人的名字，但她后来意识到，为了救她，他曾多次冒着生命危险。阿比，在与这位非凡的利他主义者相遇后，你成为了一名心理学家，并开始对广义上的利他主义产生兴趣。现在，这包括那些参与此类英雄式救援的人，
but also a very select group of people whom you sought out to study. Who were these people? The first group of people that I chose to study to try to understand real-world extraordinary altruism was altruistic kidney donors, or as they're sometimes called, non-directed kidney donors, who give a kidney to an anonymous stranger knowing they may never meet them or know
还有一小群你特意寻找并进行研究的特定人群。这些人是谁？我为了解现实世界中非凡的利他主义而选择研究的第一群人，是利他主义肾脏捐献者，或者有时被称为非定向肾脏捐献者，他们在捐献时明知可能永远不会见到对方，也无法得知对方的任何情况，却将肾脏捐献给一个素不相识的陌生人。
anything about what happened to them at the time of the donation. And I chose altruistic kidney donors to study in part because it had only very recently become even permissible in the United States to donate a kidney to a stranger and at the time it was very very very rare. And luckily, there are databases of people who have donated kidneys to strangers. So I was able to reach out to start recruiting participants that way. When you began identifying and working with these donors,
我选择研究利他主义肾脏捐献者，部分原因在于，在美国，将肾脏捐献给陌生人直到最近才获得法律允许，而在当时，这非常非常罕见。幸运的是，有一些数据库记录了向陌生人捐献过肾脏的人。因此我能够通过这种方式联系并开始招募参与者。当你开始识别并与这些捐献者合作时，
you were struck by the characteristics they seemed to share. One was their willingness to help you with the research. Yes, it was incredible. When you're studying a rare group of people, which I have done in other contexts, it sometimes can take a long time, years, to recruit enough people to fill even a small study. And I was shocked when I started recruiting altruistic kidney donors, that the very first missive I sent out, asking for altruistic kidney donors to please reach out if they would like to participate in research,
他们的共同特征让你大吃一惊。其中之一就是他们愿意协助你的研究。是的，这太不可思议了。当你研究一个稀有人群时——我在其他背景下也做过——有时可能需要很长时间，甚至数年，才能招募到足够的人来完成哪怕一项小型研究。而当我开始招募利他主义肾脏捐献者时，我感到震惊的是，我发出的第一封信——请求利他主义肾脏捐献者如果愿意参与研究请主动联系——
I had sent right before leaving for a conference. And I remember getting to the conference, sitting down in the coffee shop of the hotel, I think, opening my laptop to check my email and seeing an absolute flood of emails from people who had donated kidneys to strangers, offering to participate in research in the most cheerful and just helpful way
是我在动身去参加一个会议之前发出的。我记得到达会议地点后，我坐在酒店的咖啡厅里，打开笔记本电脑检查电子邮件，看到了一大批来自向陌生人捐献过肾脏的人的电子邮件，他们以你能想象到的最开朗、最乐于助人的方式主动提出参与研究。
you could possibly imagine. One young man from the Midwest told you that he was interested in taking part, but would need a few months to save up for a plane ticket in order to come and be part of your study. He did. He did. I couldn't believe it. I said, no, no, no, no, of course, we will pay. You don't have to pay to take part in our research. We will cover everything for you. It was incredible. But really what it indicated was not just his willingness to take part in this, but his
来自中西部的一名年轻人告诉你，他有兴趣参与，但需要几个月的时间来存钱买机票，以便前来参与你的研究。他确实这么做了。我简直不敢相信。我说：“不，不，不，不，当然了，我们会付钱的。你不用自己掏钱来参加我们的研究。我们会为你报销一切。”这太不可思议了。但实际上，这表明的不仅是他愿意参与其中，
willingness, in fact, to make further sacrifices to take part in the study. his willingness, in fact, to make further sacrifices to take part in the study. Absolutely. And taking part in research is an altruistic thing to do, because we don't compensate very much, unfortunately. We can't. And that's also by design. We don't want to be coercive and pay so much money
事实上，他还愿意为了参与这项研究做出进一步的牺牲。事实确实如此，并且参与研究本身就是一件很利他主义的事情，因为不幸的是，我们的补偿并不多。我们不能给太多。这也是有意设计的。我们不想具有强制性，支付太多的钱，
that people will do it just for the money, even if it's something they don't want to do. And so by design, psychology research is set up to require a little bit of altruism. And I discovered just how much altruism plays a part when I started recruiting people who are altruistic. So once you got these volunteers into your lab and started to study them, you found that extreme altruists,
以至于人们仅仅为了钱去做这件事，即使这不是他们想做的事。因此，从设计上讲，心理学研究需要有一点利他主义。当我开始招募那些具有利他主义的人时，我才发现利他主义在其中扮演了多大的角色。所以，一旦你把这些志愿者请进实验室并开始研究他们，你就会发现极端利他主义者——
as you came to call them, display a very high sensitivity to when other people might be frightened. Tell me about this research, Abby. The germ of this research was research I had conducted previously in people who were at the opposite end of what I call the caring continuum. So people vary quite a bit in their capacity to care about other people's welfare.
正如你后来所称呼的那样，他们对他人的恐惧表现出非常高的敏感度。告诉我这项研究，阿比。这项研究的萌芽是我之前对处于我所谓的关怀连续体另一端的人群进行的研究。因此，人们在关心他人福祉的能力上存在相当大的差异。
And at the low end of this continuum are people who are psychopathic. So people who have callous personalities and engage in frequent antisocial behavior. And what we've known from over a decade of research with people who are psychopathic is that they tend to be insensitive to other people's distress.
在这个连续体的低端是那些具精神病态特质的人。也就是那些性格冷酷、频繁做出反社会行为的人。通过对具有精神病态特质的人进行十多年的研究，我们所了解到的情况是，他们往往对其他人的痛苦表现得麻木不仁。
They have trouble recognizing it. So if they see the face of somebody who's afraid, they might not even know what the expression is called. A friend of mine, Essie Beading, in the United Kingdom, was testing a psychopathic person in a jail once about their ability to recognize emotional facial expressions. And this man failed to recognize every single fearful facial expression that she showed him. And he knew he was doing badly, and that is a pretty bad performance even for somebody who's psychopathic, because when he got to the very last fearful expression, he said,
他们很难识别这种痛苦。因此，如果他们看到一张害怕的面孔，他们甚至可能不知道这种表情叫什么。我在英国的一个朋友埃西·贝丁 (Essie Beading) 曾在监狱里测试过一个具精神病态特质的人，测试他识别面部情绪表情的能力。这个男人未能识别出她向他展示的每一个惊恐的面部表情。而且他知道自己表现很差，对于一个具精神病态特质的人来说，这都是相当糟糕的表现，因为当他看到最后一个惊恐的表情时，他说：
you know, I don't know what that expression is called, but I know that's what people look like right before you stab them. And this reveals a real sort of emotional blindness to other people's distress, which may help us understand why people who are psychopathic are so callous in response to other people's distress. They don't even really know how to interpret it very well. And the origin of that is partly deficits in a brain structure called the amygdala. And the amygdala is a complicated brain structure.
“你知道，我不知道那个表情叫什么，但我知道人们在你要捅死他们之前就是长那样的。”这揭示了一种对他人痛苦的真正的情感盲目性，这可能有助于我们理解为什么具精神病态特质的人在面对他人的痛苦时会如此冷酷无情。他们甚至不太清楚如何很好地解读它。而这背后的根源部分在于大脑中一个叫做杏仁核的结构的缺陷。杏仁核是一个复杂的大脑结构。
It does a lot of different things. But it's not essential for structure called the amygdala. And the amygdala is a complicated brain structure. It does a lot of different things. But it's not essential for doing that many things. One of the things that seems to be really important for doing is representing fear in other people. So generating an internal representation of that state that helps you then recognize it in others. And what we hypothesized at the beginning of our research with altruistic people is that if very uncaring people seem to be unusually insensitive to other people's distress, and
它有很多不同的功能。但它并不是执行那么多功能所必不可少的。它似乎非常重要的功能之一，就是在其他人身上表征恐惧。从而在内部生成那种状态的表征，进而帮助你在其他人身上识别出它。我们在对利他主义者进行研究之初假设，如果那些非常冷漠的人似乎对别人的痛苦异常不敏感，而
that is underpinned by deficits in a structure called the amygdala, both in its reduced activation in response to other people's distress and its lower volume. So people who are psychopathic have amygdala that are usually small on average. Maybe people who aren't usually caring and highly altruistic will look exactly the opposite. They'll be sensitive to other people's distress, better recognizing it,
这是由一个叫做杏仁核的结构的缺陷所支撑的——无论是在应对他人痛苦时激活度降低，还是体积较小。因此，具精神病态特质的人的杏仁核平均而言通常很小。也许那些通常富有同情心且高度利他的人看起来会完全相反。他们会对别人的痛苦敏感，能更好地识别它，
and we would see increased amygdala activation in response to that distress, and maybe larger amygdalas as well. So those were our hypothesis setting out. Is that what you found? That was exactly what we found. The altruistic people that we tested on our very first study looked the opposite of people who were psychopathic. They were relatively better at recognizing other people's fear and they were not better at recognizing other expressions. So we also tested how well they recognized anger and they didn't recognize anger better. In fact, they recognized it a little worse.
并且我们会看到针对这种痛苦的杏仁核激活度增加，也许杏仁核也会更大。这就是我们出发时的假设。那是你发现的结果吗？这正是我们所发现的。我们在第一项研究中测试的利他主义者看起来与具精神病态特质的人截然相反。他们相对更擅长识别别人的恐惧，但并不擅长识别其他表情。所以我们也测试了他们对愤怒的识别能力，他们识别愤怒并没有更好。事实上，他们识别得稍微差一点。
But they were very specifically sensitive to other people's distress. And we also found that in our brain scanning studies, their amygdala showed more activation in response to images of other people's fear, whereas again, it did not show that response to other people's anger. And finally, their amygdalas were on average about 8% larger than in a comparable group of adults that we also tested who were not altruistic kidney donors. So another characteristic of extraordinary altruists that you identified was a dramatically reduced tendency to engage in what psychologists call social discounting. What is social discounting, Abby?
但他们对别人的痛苦有着非常特殊的敏感性。我们还在脑部扫描研究中发现，在面对他人恐惧的图像时，他们的杏仁核表现出更多的激活，然而同样，他们对他人的愤怒并没有表现出这种反应。最后，与我们测试的另一组不是利他主义肾脏捐献者的对照组成年人相比，他们的杏仁核平均要大 8% 左右。你发现的非凡利他主义者的另一个特征是，他们表现出一种显著降低的倾向，即从事心理学家所说的社会贴现。什么是社会贴现，阿比？
So social discounting reflects how you value other people's outcomes as a function of their social distance from you. Basically, how much are you willing to sacrifice to benefit another person? And most people in standard social discounting tasks are very willing to sacrifice to benefit people close to them, but their willingness to sacrifice drops dramatically, hyperbolically, as people become more socially distant. So in other words, if I have, you know, $100, sharing it with a partner or a parent or a child, very easy to do. Sharing it with someone whom I don't know at all, very unlikely I'm going to do it at all.
因此，社会贴现反映了你如何根据他人与你的社会距离来评估他们的结果。基本上，你愿意为造福他人牺牲多少？在标准的社会贴现任务中，大多数人非常愿意做出牺牲来造福与自己亲近的人，但随着人们在社会距离上变得越来越疏远，他们愿意牺牲的意愿会急剧地、双曲线式地下降。换句话说，如果我有，你知道的，100 美元，把它分给伴侣、父母或孩子，这很容易做到。把它分给一个我完全不认识的人，我几乎不可能这么做。
Exactly. And across testing sessions and countries, we see that people have very limited desire to share resources, to sacrifice, to benefit people that they don't know or barely know. that they don't know or barely know. And what did you find with the extraordinary altruists? When we tested the altruistic kidney donors in the social discounting task, we found a curve unlike any that's ever been found in any social discounting task, which was a curve that dropped almost not at all across social distances. So people who donate kidneys to strangers are willing to sacrifice as much to help a stranger as most people are willing to sacrifice to help somewhere between a distant friend and an acquaintance, even though they don't know that person at all.
没错。跨越不同的测试环节和国家，我们发现人们分享资源、做出牺牲以造福那些他们不认识或几乎不认识的人的愿望非常有限。他们不认识或几乎不认识的人。那么你在非凡利他主义者身上发现了什么？当我们在社会贴现任务中测试利他主义肾脏捐献者时，我们发现了一条不同于以往任何社会贴现任务中发现的曲线，这是一条在社会距离跨度上几乎没有下降的曲线。因此，向陌生人捐献肾脏的人愿意为了帮助陌生人做出牺牲，其程度与大多数人愿意为了帮助介于远亲和熟人之间的人做出牺牲的程度相当，尽管他们根本不认识那个人。
That person's welfare clearly intrinsically matters to them. So in other words, it's almost as if the circle of who they thought as being connected to them was just much, much larger. Exactly. They have a much wider circle of caring. They view the outcomes of people they've never met before as intrinsically valuable, as something that it's worth caring about and worth sacrificing for. You met one kidney donor named Harold Mince whose attitude exemplifies this phenomenon of reduced social discounting. Tell me his story, Abby.
那个人的福祉对他们来说显然具有内在的重要性。换句话说，这几乎就像他们认为与自己有联系的圈子要大得多、广得多。没错。他们的关怀圈要广得多。他们将他们从未见过面的人的结果视为具有内在价值的，视为值得关怀和值得为之牺牲的事物。你遇到过一位名叫 Harold Mince 的肾脏捐献者，他的态度体现了这种社会贴现减少的现象。讲讲他的故事吧，阿比。
So Harold was one of the first altruistic kidney donors in the country and he was the first in Washington, D.C. He actually donated at Georgetown where I work. And Harold came up with the idea to donate a kidney to a stranger on his own. He had never known anybody who'd done it before, but he knew you could donate bone marrow to strangers and he knew you could donate kidneys to people you know. And so he thought, hey, if I could donate a kidney to somebody I know, and I don't know
所以 Harold 是国内最早的利他主义肾脏捐献者之一，也是华盛顿特区的第一位。他实际上是在我工作的乔治城大学捐献的。Harold 是自己萌生了向陌生人捐献肾脏的想法的。他从未认识过任何做过此事的人，但他知道你可以向陌生人捐献骨髓，他也知道你可以向认识的人捐献肾脏。于是他想，嘿，如果我可以把肾脏捐给一个我认识的人，而我又不认识
anybody that needs a kidney, why don't I just donate to somebody that needs a kidney? And so he called around to several transplantation organizations and they sent him a bunch of pamphlets for deceased donation. And he said, that's not what I want. I want to donate to somebody now who needs my kidney. And he didn't hear anything for a while. And then eventually they ran a pilot program in DC to try non-directed altruistic kidney donation. The person that was chosen to receive Harold's kidney was a woman who had no eligible donors in her own circle
任何需要肾脏的人，我为什么不直接捐给需要肾脏的人呢？于是他打电话给几家移植组织，他们寄给他一堆关于逝者捐献的小册子。他说：“这不是我想要的。我想现在就捐给需要我肾脏的人。”有一段时间他没有听到任何消息。后来，他们最终在华盛顿特区开展了一个试点项目，尝试非定向的利他主义肾脏捐献。被选中接受 Harold 肾脏的人是一位女性，她自己的亲友圈里没有符合捐献条件的捐献者，
and other people had been tested and was dying of kidney disease. It's an awful disease. Living on dialysis is like a living death is how people describe it. And Harold didn't know who she was when he decided to donate to her. He went into surgery, had a kidney removed, it was planted into his recipient. Transplant surgeons describe it as a Lazarus effect. When there are very few diseases like this that you can perform a surgery,
其他人也接受了测试，她正因肾病濒临死亡。这是一种可怕的疾病。人们将靠透析生活形容为生不如死。当 Harold 决定把肾脏捐给她时，他并不知道她是谁。他走进手术室，切除了一颗肾脏，并将其植入受者体内。移植外科医生将其描述为“拉撒路效应”（死而复生）。很少有这样的疾病能让你做完手术后，
the kidney starts working immediately, it starts producing urine right away, and the person is like brought back to life. You know, that a plant that has been watered in a time lapse is how quickly they're restored to health and life and vigor. And it was a tremendous success. I'm sure it contributed to the fact that we now have programs like this on a wider scale. And Harold and his recipients remain very good friends to this day. So one of the things that's striking about Harold and some of the other
肾脏立刻开始工作，马上开始产生尿液，受者就像复活了一样。你知道的，延时摄影中浇过水的植物就是他们恢复健康、生命力和精力的速度。这是一次巨大的成功。我相信这促进了我们现在能够更大规模地开展此类项目。直到今天，Harold 和他的受者仍然是非常好的朋友。所以，关于 Harold 和你交谈过的一些其他
donors that you spoke with is that these donors often don't feel like their altruism requires an explanation. When you ask them, you know, why are you so altruistic? Their question is, why isn't everyone so altruistic? Yes, that's one of the most important things to know about altruistic kidney donors is that although many people who themselves would not consider donating a kidney find the choice to donate a kidney to a stranger in need of explanation, actual donors feel exactly the opposite. They think if you have two kidneys and you could survive just fine with one, which is true, that if another person is going to die unless they get your kidney, the choice to
捐献者，令人印象深刻的一点是，这些捐献者通常不觉得他们的利他主义需要解释。当你问他们：“你知道的，你为什么这么利他？”他们的反问是：“为什么不是每个人都这么利他？”是的，这是关于利他主义肾脏捐献者最重要的事情之一，尽管许多本身不考虑捐献肾脏的人会觉得把肾脏捐献给素不其素的陌生人这一选择需要解释，但真正的捐献者却有截然相反的感受。他们认为如果你有两个肾脏，只用一个也能活得很好——这是事实，如果另一个人除非得到你的肾脏就会死去，那么选择
donate to them is the obvious choice. It feels to them so intuitive and so clear that they have trouble understanding why anybody wouldn't make that decision. Another distinguishing characteristic of these altruists was their striking sense of humility. Can you talk about this idea, Abby? Yes, it was something I was really surprised to discover when I started working with altruistic kidney donors. And I thought maybe how humble they were about their choice to donate was sort of, you know, just a quirky little bug. But I now believe it's an intrinsic feature
捐献给他们就是显而易见的选择。这让他们感到如此直观和清晰，以至于他们很难理解为什么有人会不做出这个决定。这些利他主义者的另一个显著特征是他们具有惊人的谦逊感。你能谈谈这个想法吗？阿比？是的，这是我开始与利他主义肾脏捐献者合作时感到非常惊讶的一点。我曾以为他们对自己捐献选择的谦逊可能只是一种古怪的小癖好，但我现在相信这是帮助他人的决定中
of the decision to help other people. Many donors I've worked with, I would say most donors, including Harold, have told me that they're happy to take part in my research, they're glad I'm doing it, but they're pretty sure I'm not gonna find any differences between them and other adults because there's nothing special
的一个内在特征。我合作过的许多捐献者，我想说大多数捐献者，包括 Harold，都告诉我他们很高兴参与我的研究，他们很高兴我在做这件事，但他们很确信我不会发现他们与其他成年人之间有什么区别，因为他们或任何其他想捐肾的人
about them or anybody else who wants to donate a kidney. It's just a function of having the right information, being in the right place at the right time. It's something anybody could do. And I've had many altruists reassure me that there's nothing special about them. And that to me makes perfect sense because if you really do believe that you're the most special person, why would you want to share with somebody less special?
并没有什么特别之处。这只拥有正确信息、在正确的时间出现在正确地点的结果。这是任何人都能做到的事。许多利他主义者向我保证，他们没有什么特别的。这对我来说完全说得通，因为如果你真的认为自己是最特别的人，你为什么还要跟一个不那么特别的人分享呢？
That doesn't make any sense. The most special person should have all the kidneys. But if you're such a humble person that you don't think you're any more special than anybody else, it does make complete sense that you would say, well, why should me, who's not in any way special, have all the kidney resources? It really makes much more sense to allocate them among anybody who happens to need one. One of these very humble altruists is the actor Danny Trejo. For listeners who might not be familiar with him, tell me what kind of roles he portrays
这毫无道理。最特别的人应该拥有所有的肾脏。但如果你是一个如此谦逊的人，不认为自己比任何其他人更特别，那么你说“好吧，为什么我这个在任何方面都不特别的人应该拥有所有的肾脏资源呢？”就完全说得通了。把它们分配给碰巧需要一个的任何人，才真正更有意义。其中一位非常谦逊的利他主义者是演员丹尼·特乔 (Danny Trejo)。对于可能不太熟悉他的听众，告诉我他扮演的是什么类型的角色，
and how he came to your attention. I'm familiar with Danny Trejo from his role in Spy Kids, where he plays a villain, as he often does in the movies, because he has this very gravelly sounding voice and a craggy face and looks very forbidding. And so he usually plays villains in the movies. And so how did he come to your attention as an altruist? Well he was in the news for something very altruistic and heroic that he did. He was running errands, I think near his home one day, when he witnessed a terrifying car
他是怎么引起你的注意的？我知道丹尼·特乔是因为他在《非常小特务》中的角色，他在片中扮演一个恶人，就像他在电影中经常做的那样，因为他有着非常沙哑的声音和饱经风霜的脸，看起来非常令人敬畏。所以他通常在电影中扮演恶人。那么他怎么作为一名利他主义者引起你的注意的呢？嗯，他因为做了一件非常利他且英勇的事情而上了新闻。有一天，他正在家附近跑腿，目睹了一场可怕的车祸，
crash when a sedan next to his car collided with an SUV and it resulted in this chain reaction that flipped this SUV upside down and inside was trapped a little boy who I believe had special needs along with his mother and his grandma and Trejo as is often the case in these situations reacted immediately he could smell gas trickling out of the wreckage of the cars but but despite that, he crawled into the SUV, which was up died down at that point, and figured out how to extract the boy from the car and then sat by him and helped keep him calm while emergency rescuers got the rest of his family out of the car. So I understand that when people ask him afterwards, you know, why he had done what he did, again, he didn't draw particular attention to himself.
一辆轿车与他车旁的一辆 SUV 相撞，这引发了一连串的反应，将这辆 SUV 翻了个底朝天，里面困着一个小男孩——我相信他有特殊需求，还有他的妈妈和奶奶。和这种情况下通常发生的情况一样，特乔立刻做出了反应。他能闻到汽油从汽车的残骸中渗漏出来，
He didn't single himself out as special. Absolutely. His quotation was perfectly characteristic of how so many altruists and heroes describe their own actions. What he said afterward was, people have to understand that God put us on this earth to help each other. We're here to serve, we're here to welcome, we're here to love. That's what we're supposed to be doing.
但尽管如此，他还是爬进了当时已经底朝天倒置的 SUV 中，想方设法把男孩从车里救了出来，然后坐在他身旁，帮他保持冷静，直到紧急救援人员把他的其他家人从车里救出来。所以我听说当人们后来问他：“你知道的，你为什么要这样做”时，他同样没有特别引人注目地吸引人们对自己的关注。
I'm just thankful to God because he let me do that today. I think the implicit message was, it's not about me. I'm not special. I was just doing what any of us should do and what any of us could do in a similar situation. So Abhi, your research has also found that these altruists not only feel that strangers are as worthy of their help as loved ones, they also engage in mental processes that orient them toward taking action to help strangers. Can you talk
他没有把自己挑出来说自己很特殊。绝对没有。他说的话非常典型地代表了许多利他主义者和英雄如何描述他们自己的行动。他事后所说的是：“人们必须明白，上帝把我们放在这个地球上是为了互相帮助。我们是为了服务而在这里，我们是为了欢迎而在这里，我们是为了爱而在这里。这才是我们应该做的事。”
about this research? Well, the researchers who study emotion know that there are different ways that you can appraise emotional situations or interpret those situations that do change the way that you're likely to act in those situations. When you see a distressing situation, if somebody is in danger, for example, it's very upsetting.
我只是感谢上帝，因为他让我今天做成了那件事。我想其中隐含的信息是：这与我无关。我不特殊。我只是在做我们任何人都应该做的事，也是我们在类似情况下任何人都能够做的事。所以，阿比，你的研究还发现，这些利他主义者不仅觉得陌生人和挚爱一样值得他们帮助，他们还会进行一些心理过程，引导他们采取行动去帮助陌生人。你能谈谈
And sometimes people tend to interpret those situations in a way that reduces their own negative feelings, but doesn't induce them to act. For example, there's probably nothing I can do, somebody else will help, for example. But there are also hopeful ways that you could appraise situations like that. For example, I bet that there's something I can do
这项研究吗？嗯，研究情绪的研究人员知道，你可以通过不同的方式来评估情绪状况或解读这些状况，这确实会改变你在这些情况下采取行动的可能性。当你看到一个令人痛苦的情况时，例如如果有人处于危险之中，这是非常令人沮丧的。
to alleviate that person's distress. Maybe I could donate money in a way that would help people like this elsewhere in the world. And we did find in a study that we conducted of altruists and controls that having a more hopeful appraisal pattern was associated with being more likely to help people in need. You may have noticed a pattern in the extreme altruists that Abby has studied. Like Danny Trejo or the man who rescued Abby on the freeway, they don't arrive at the decision to be altruistic by thinking through all the pros and cons. They arrive at their decisions quickly, intuitively, sometimes instantaneously. One of the really interesting things about altruistic
有时人们倾向于以某种方式解读这些情况，从而减少他们自己的负面情绪，但不会促使他们采取行动。例如，“我可能无能为力，别人会帮忙的”——这是一种例子。但也有一些充满希望的方式来评估这样Situations（情况）。例如，“我敢打赌，我一定能做点什么来减轻那个人的痛苦。”也许我可以捐款，以一种能够帮助世界上其他地方处于这种困境的人的方式。我们在对利他主义者和对照组进行的研究所发现的是，拥有更具希望的评估模式与更有可能帮助有需要的人有关。你可能已经注意到阿比研究的极端利他主义者身上的一种模式。就像丹尼·特乔或在高速公路上救了阿比的那个男人一样，他们并不是通过权衡所有利弊来得出利他主义的决定的。他们的决定来得很快、凭直觉，有时甚至是瞬间完成的。关于利他主义，一件非常有趣的事情是
kidney donors is even though they do have a lot of time to make their decision, it's not sort of flash decision they have to make like a heroic rescuer, they do report that the decision itself was made very quickly and spontaneously. They discover that it's possible to donate a kidney to a stranger and that there's tens of thousands of Americans in need of a kidney on the waiting list. And they often think essentially immediately, I'll do it. I would love to do that. So you tell the story of a man who leaped into action without really thinking very much about it. His
肾脏捐献者虽然确实有很多时间来做决定，这不是那种像英雄救援人员那样必须仓促做出的决定，但他们确实报告说，这个决定本身是非常迅速和自发地做出的。他们发现把肾脏捐给一个陌生人是可能的，而且等待名单上有成万上千的美国人需要肾脏。他们通常基本上立刻就会想：我来做。我很乐意这么做。所以你讲了一个男人没有多加思考就挺身而出的故事。他的
name was Lenny Scutnick and this happened back in 1982. Can you tell me his story, Abby? Lenny Scutnick was a government worker who in the early 80s was carpooling home from his job in DC to Virginia and while he was in the car, a plane taking off from Reagan National Airport crashed into the Potomac River. It was a really horrific plane crash. And of course, all the traffic backed up on the bridge and Skutnik ended up getting out and walking to the bridge and seeing all of these people who miraculously had survived the crash, but now were slowly freezing to death and or drowning in the icy river. It was the middle of winter
名字叫伦尼·斯库特尼克，这发生在1982年。艾比，你能讲讲他的故事吗？伦尼·斯库特尼克是一名政府工作人员，在80年代初，他下班后搭车从华盛顿特区回弗吉尼亚州的家。当他在车里时，一架从里根国家机场起飞的飞机坠入了波托马克河。那是一场非常可怕的飞机坠毁事故。当然，桥上的所有交通都堵塞了，斯库特尼克最终下车走到桥上，看到了所有这些奇迹般在坠机中幸存下来，但现在却在冰冷的河水中慢慢冻死或溺水的人。当时正值严冬，
and the de-icing problem had been why the plane had crashed. And obviously it took crews a long time to get to the scene of the crash in part because of all the backups. And Skutnik incredibly decided that he was going to help. And he walked down to the banks of the Potomac, and I think he took off his shoes and his coat and leaped into the river and ended up rescuing a woman who had been clinging, I think, to a piece of ice or a piece of wreckage in the river and bringing her to shore,
飞机坠毁的原因正是除冰问题。显然，救援人员花了很长时间才到达坠机现场，部分原因是因为交通大塞车。而斯库特尼克竟然决定去帮忙，这太不可思议了。他走到波托马克河岸边，我想他脱掉了鞋子和大衣，跳进河里，最终救出了一名紧紧抓着河里一块浮冰或残骸的女性，把她带到了岸边，
at enormous risk to his own life. And when you talk with these people, when you talk with these extraordinary altruists, you often find that they do not use the language of rationality to explain their actions. So they're not basically saying this is a cost-benefit equation. Perhaps after the fact, they say, you know, this is a cost-benefit equation. But in the moment, that's not how they're coming to their conclusions, is it? Absolutely not. No, they almost always report that they didn't even think about anything before they started to act. That oftentimes they hardly even realized what they were doing until they were in the middle of
冒着极大的生命危险。当你与这些人交谈时，当你与这些非凡的利他主义者交谈时，你经常会发现他们并不用理性的语言来解释他们的行为。所以他们基本上不是在说这是一个成本效益方程。也许事后他们会说，你知道，这是一个成本效益方程。但在当时，他们并不是这样得出结论的，对吗？绝对不是。不，他们几乎总是报告说，在开始行动之前，他们甚至根本没有考虑任何事情。很多时候，他们甚至还没意识到自己在做什么，就已经身处
rescuing somebody. And that afterwards they often think, oh my gosh, I could have really been badly hurt or something else terrible could have happened. But in the moment, no, they're not thinking about the the risks and cost to themselves at all. They really act immediately on a very, I think, sort of deep impulse. The extraordinary altruists that Abby brought into our lab might seem superhuman. But her research offers clues that selflessness might be more common than we imagine. When we come back, why all of us already possess the capacity for extraordinary altruism and how we can cultivate it. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. If you have follow-up questions, comments, or stories about altruism and generosity that you'd be comfortable sharing with the Hidden
救援某人的过程中了。事后他们经常会想，哦天哪，我当时真的可能会受重伤，或者可能会发生其他可怕的事情。但在当时，不，他们根本没有考虑对自身的风险和成本。他们真的只是根据一种非常深刻的冲动立刻采取了行动。艾比带到我们实验室的非凡利他主义者可能看起来像超人。但她的研究提供的线索表明，无私可能比我们想象的更常见。当我们回来时，将探讨为什么我们所有人其实都具备非凡利他主义的潜能，以及我们该如何培养它。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。如果您有关于利他主义和慷慨的后续问题、评论或故事，并愿意与《隐藏的大
Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, generosity. Abigail Marsh is a psychologist and neuroscientist at Georgetown University. She is the author of The Fear Factor, How One Emotion Connects Altruists, Psychopaths, and Everyone in Between. From what we've heard so far, Abby, extraordinary altruists seem impossibly different from the rest of us.
大脑》的听众分享，请在手机上录制语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。主题请写：慷慨。阿比盖尔·马什是乔治敦大学的心理学家和神经科学家。她是《恐惧因子：一种情绪如何将利他主义者、精神病患者及所有人连接在一起》一书的作者。艾比，从我们目前听到的情况来看，非凡利他主义者似乎与我们其余人有着不可思议的巨大差异。
But actually, you say that the capacity to care deeply about others is woven into our species as a whole? Absolutely. I think many people are surprised when I say that humans are an unusually altruistic species, but there's no question about it, we are. If you look across, for example, other primate species, humans an unusually altruistic species, but there's no question about it, we are. If you look across, for example, other primate species,
但实际上，你说深深关爱他人的能力已经融入了我们整个物种之中？绝对是的。当我这样说时，很多人可能会感到惊讶，因为人类是一个异常利他的人类物种，但这是毫无疑问的，我们确实如此。如果你看看其他灵长类物种，人类是一个异常利他的人类物种，但这是毫无疑问的，我们确实如此。如果你看看其他灵长类物种，
humans are the most altruistic. They're the most likely to share freely with other people with no expectation of benefit for themselves. And the reason seems to be, maybe a little bit surprisingly, that humans are also what's called an alloparental species. And that means that human adults are prepared to care and do care for infants who are not
人类是最具利他精神的。他们最倾向于无私地与他人分享，而不期望为自己带来任何好处。原因似乎是，也许有点令人意外，人类也是所谓的“同种异亲抚育”（alloparental）物种。这意味着人类成年人准备好并且确实在照顾并非
their own. And that's not something you see in that many primate species. But if you look across species, the very best predictor of how altruistic a species is, is how much care they provide for babies that are not their own. And humans do this a lot. And it seems to be the best explanation for why we're so altruistic. And of course, when you think about doctors or the medical system or nurses, it's the same idea, right? People are devoted in some ways to caring for others in a way that really is very
自己亲生的婴儿。你在许多灵长类物种中是看不到这一点的。但如果你跨物种观察，衡量一个物种利他程度的最佳预测指标，就是它们为非亲生婴儿提供多少照顾。而人类经常这样做。这似乎是对我们为什么如此具有利他精神的最佳解释。当然，当你想到医生、医疗系统或护士时，也是同样的道理，对吧？人们在某种程度上致力于照顾他人，当你仔细想想并将其与其他物种的行为进行对比时，这种方式确实非常
unusual when you think about it and think about what other species do. It's truly astonishing. And I think one of the reasons it's easy to forget is we spend so much of our life immersed in stories about the worst things that happen all around the world, which of course, unfortunately, is what, you know, many social media and some traditional media sources are incentivized to tell us about. And all that information pours into our brain about the terrible things that people do, and it can leave people with sort of a cynical view that, oh, humans are so awful, we do such awful things. But what I always tell people is think about the interactions you have. Think about the people around you in your real life that you spend time with and that
不寻常。这真的令人惊叹。我认为我们很容易忘记这一点的原因之一是，我们生活中的大部分时间都沉浸在世界各地发生的各种最糟糕事情的故事中，当然，不幸的是，许多社交媒体和一些传统媒体正是靠向我们宣传这些来获取激励的。所有这些关于人们所做的可怕事情的信息倾注到我们的大脑中，这可能会让人产生一种愤世嫉俗的观点，即“哦，人类太可怕了，我们做出了这么多可怕的事情”。但我总是告诉人们的是：想想你的日常互动。想想你现实生活中与之相处和
you interact with. How have those interactions been? Have those people generally been pretty helpful, pretty cooperative, willing to help each other out in a pinch? And when you do that, I think most people think, oh my gosh, I'm really lucky. I spend my life surrounded by a lot of really nice people. ["The Last Supper"] You and others have also pointed out
互动的周围人。那些互动感觉如何？那些人在遇到困难时，通常都相当乐于助人、相当合作、愿意互相帮助吗？当你这样思考时，我想大多数人都觉得，哦天哪，我真的很幸运。我的生活中周围有许多非常好的人。《最后的晚餐》你和其他人也指出，
that even within human societies, there seems to be a historical trend where this kind of generalized caring is becoming more common and is being extended in some ways to ever-widening circles of people. Can you talk about that idea that even when we look down history, we might actually be more generous and altruistic now than people, let's say, 500 or 1,000 years ago? That's certainly true. Humans, we believe, evolved to live in societies of 100 to 150 people, where they very rarely
即使在人类社会内部，也似乎存在着一种历史趋势：这种普遍的关爱正变得越来越普遍，并在某些方面扩展到不断扩大的群体中。你能谈谈这个观点吗？即使我们回溯历史，与比如说500年或1000年前的人相比，我们现在实际上可能更慷慨、更具利他精神？这肯定是事实。我们认为，人类进化生活在100到150人的社会中，在那个环境里，他们极少
would have encountered strangers. And when they did, it was just as likely to be a dangerous interaction as one in which there would be any cooperation. And it's only quite recently, in the course of our species' history, that we've even had the capacity to know what is happening to people on the other side of the world and people that we've even had the capacity to know what is happening to people on the other side of the world and people that we've never met before. Nevermind help them.
会遇到陌生人。即使遇到了，那也既可能是一次危险的互动，也可能是一次存在合作可能的互动。直到在我们物种历史的相当晚近时期，我们才具备了能力去了解世界上另一端以及我们从未谋面的人身上正发生着什么事情，甚至具备了去了解世界上另一端以及我们从未谋面的人身上正发生着什么事情的能力。更不用说去帮助他们了。
And so I think in that context, it's really remarkable just how much time and energy and money people spend trying to help people who don't live in their town, don't live in their country, they've never met, they never will meet, but still that person's welfare matters enough that people, many people, are willing to give and help. You say that a hundred years ago people would have thought it ludicrous to donate, you know, their blood and bone marrow to complete strangers today. So in
所以我想在这种背景下，人们花那么多时间、精力和金钱去试图帮助那些不住在他们镇上、不住在他们国家、从未谋面、也永远不会谋面的人，这真的是一件非常了不起的事。但尽管如此，这些人的福祉仍然足够重要，以至于许多人愿意付出和提供帮助。你说过，一百年前的人们会觉得把自己的血液和骨髓捐献给完全的陌生人是荒唐可笑的。所以从
some ways it's possible that, you know, maybe 100 years from now, people will think that donating a kidney to a stranger is just as normal and ordinary as we think donating blood is today. Absolutely. I think many people are unaware of just how strange it was considered when blood donation first became a thing that anybody would want to open up their veins
某种意义上说，也许100年后，人们会认为把肾脏捐给陌生人就像我们今天认为献血一样正常和寻常，这也是有可能的。绝对是的。我认为许多人并不知道，当献血刚开始成为一种人们愿意打开自己的静脉，
and let blood be taken out by a stranger and given to another stranger. And in fact, you know, there are many places in the world where people really don't give blood in this way. But I think in part because people are becoming generally more altruistic and certainly more altruistic toward a widening group of people over time. And as that is happening, things like blood donation are becoming more normative. And so it's become sort of a matter of course for many people.
让陌生人把血抽出来再输给另一个陌生人的行为时，它曾被认为是多么奇怪的一件事。事实上，你知道，世界上许多地方的人们实际上并不以这种方式献血。但我认为部分原因是，随着时间的推移，人们普遍变得更具利他精神，对不断扩大的群体也确实更加利他。随着这种趋势的发生，像献血这样的事情正在变得越来越规范化。因此，对许多人来说，这已经变成了一种理所当然的事情。
That blood donation is something you do, if there's a national emergency, if there's a blood shortage, this is a way that we can all pitch in to help. And so it's gone from, I think, at one time being a somewhat extraordinarily altruistic thing to do to being a more ordinary form of altruism. And I hope that in the future, rare forms of altruism like donating bone marrow or donating organs will maybe follow the same course.
献血成了这样一件事：如果有国家紧急情况，如果出现血荒，这是我们大家都可以出一份力来帮忙的方式。因此，我认为它已经从曾经的一种极为非凡的利他行为，变成了一种更平常的利他形式。我希望在未来，像捐献骨髓或捐献器官这样罕见的利他形式也许能遵循同样的发展轨迹。
Are there differences, do you think, between countries in their capacity or willingness to exercise altruism, Abby? At the national level, we find that countries that are overall wealthier, that are healthier, people live longer, that have higher levels of education. And also where people report higher levels of flourishing and life satisfaction, we see much higher levels of altruism than countries in which both objective
艾比，你认为不同国家在行使利他主义的能力或意愿上是否存在差异？在国家层面，我们发现总体上更富裕、更健康、人均寿命更长、教育水平更高的国家，人们的利他水平要高得多；此外，那些人们报告有更高繁荣感和生活满意度的国家，其利他水平也远高于客观
and subjective well-being are lower. I mean, it is the case that there are people who hoard their wealth and billionaires who sit on their fortunes without sharing any of it. But I remember reading just recently that Bill Gates, for example, is thinking of giving away 99% of his wealth, 200 billion dollars to philanthropy.
和主观幸福感较低的国家。我的意思是，确实存在这样的人：他们囤积财富，亿万富翁坐拥巨额财富却一毛不克斯。但我最近刚读到，例如比尔·盖茨正考虑将其99%的财富——2000亿美元——捐赠给慈善事业。
And again, when you think about it from an objective standpoint, that is actually kind of crazy, right? That one person is basically saying, I have enough money to basically give to my children and grandchildren and great-grandchildren, you know, essentially from now until eternity. And he's saying, no, I want to give it away to strangers. Isn't that remarkable? I think that it's something that we should not overlook and think, oh, well, that's what billionaires are expected to do. Why would they be expected to do that?
再次从客观的角度来看，这其实有点疯狂，对吧？一个人基本上是在说：“我有足够的钱留给我的子孙后代，基本上可以从现在直到永远。”而他却说：“不，我要把它捐给陌生人。”这难道不是很了不起吗？我认为这是我们不应该忽视的，不应该觉得“哦，这本就是亿万富翁应该做的”。他们凭什么就应该这么做？
It's incredible that this is something that is so common among very wealthy people to just give their money away to help various causes. And fortunately, it is something of a norm among the very wealthy. Now, I will also say that it's true that people who are very selfish and narcissistic and greedy often desire to have a lot of money and power and status. And so, of course, there are people of any strata of the wealth distribution who are very unselfish and people who are very selfish. There's no question that that's true. And there are some very selfish people who do seem to seek out a lot of wealth. That said, if you look across the whole spectrum of objective well-being, including variables
这太不可思议了，将自己的财富捐出来帮助各种事业，这在非常富有的人当中竟然如此普遍。幸运的是，这在超级富豪中确实在某种程度上成为了一种规范。现在，我也要说，那些非常自恋、贪婪和自私的人往往确实渴望拥有大量的金钱、权力和地位。所以，在财富分配的任何阶层中，当然既有非常无私的人，也有非常自私的人。毫无疑问，这是事实。确实有一些非常自私的人似乎在极力追求大量的财富。话虽如此，如果你纵观整个客观福祉的光谱，包括诸如
like social status and wealth, on average, it seems like the better off people are, the more likely they're willing to give to help others, which I think suggests that when people have the physical and psychological resources to help other people, helping other people is the natural thing to do and it is what most people do. Can you talk a moment about how crisis and disaster in some ways, you know, unlocks the altruism that is inside many of us? It may seem a little bit paradoxical that if improved well-being leads to greater altruism, that times of crisis could also lead to greater altruism, but both things seem to be true.
社会地位和财富等变量，平均而言，生活状况越好的人，似乎就越愿意付出以帮助他人，这我认为表明：当人们拥有帮助他人的身体和心理资源时，帮助他人就是一件自然而然的事，这也是大多数人在做的事。你能花点时间谈谈，为什么危机和灾难在某种程度上能够（你知道的）释放我们许多人内心深处的利他主义吗？如果改善的福祉会导致更大的利他主义，那么危机时期也可能导致更大的利他主义，这两者看起来可能有点矛盾，但这两件事似乎都是真的。
This fact is very surprising because we're all familiar with stories like the Lord of the Flies where a disaster setting brings out the worst in people and causes them to turn on one another. But if you look at real life scenarios of crises and disasters, it's astonishingly common how often people actually band together to help one another. We saw after the COVID-19 pandemic that globally altruistic behavior went up in the aftermath of the pandemic. People actually reported giving even more help to strangers, volunteering, and donating to charity than they had before the pandemic.
这一事实非常令人惊奇，因为我们都熟悉诸如《蝇王》之类的小说故事，其中灾难环境激起了人们最坏的一面，导致他们自相残杀。但如果你看看现实生活中的危机和灾难场景，人们竟然如此频繁、惊人地团结起来互相帮助，这实在令人吃惊。我们在COVID-19大流行之后看到，全球范围内的利他行为在大流行之后有所上升。人们实际上报告说，相比大流行之前，他们向陌生人提供了更多的帮助、参与了更多的志愿服务，并向慈善机构进行了更多的捐款。
Perhaps because that acute fear response we get in times of disaster actually motivates us, it gives us the sort of urgency to help other people just the same way it gives us the sense of urgency about helping ourselves. You tell a remarkable story about a group of Florida beachgoers who noticed that there were some people who were at risk of drowning. Tell me that story. What did they do, Abby? This is an incredible story. A couple of years ago on a Florida beach, a riptide formed and sent two young boys, their parents and their grandmother way out to sea. And of course,
也许是因为我们在灾难时刻获得的这种急性恐惧反应确实激励了我们，它赋予了我们帮助他人的紧迫感，就像它赋予了我们帮助自己的紧迫感一样。你讲了一个引人入胜的故事，讲的是一群去佛罗里达海滩游玩的游客注意到有些人面临溺水的危险。请讲讲那个故事。他们做了什么，艾比？这是一个不可思议的故事。几年前在佛罗里达的一个海滩上，形成了一股离岸流，将两个小男孩、他们的父母和祖母卷到了远离海岸的海面上。当然，
riptides are very dangerous. People drown on them all the time. But what happened this particular day was that 70 strangers spontaneously formed a human chain out into the water that extended almost all the way to the drowning family. And then a woman named Jessica Simmons and her husband swam out to the end of the human chain, rescued the family, and got them all back to safety one by one. So you recently had an opportunity to perform a small act of helping. This happened in your neighborhood when you were out on a walk. Paint me a picture of what happened, Abby.
离岸流非常危险。人们经常在其中溺水。但那天发生的事情是：70名陌生人在水中自发形成了一条向外延伸的人链，几乎一直延伸到了那个溺水的家庭。随后，一位名叫杰西卡·斯托克斯（Jessica Simmons）的女士和她的丈夫游到了人链的尽头，把这一家人救了回来，一个接一个地把他们带回了安全地带。所以你最近有机会做了一件微小的助人善举。这发生在你的邻居身上，当时你正在散步。请为我描绘一下当时发生了什么，艾比？
So it was a rush hour, a busy morning, and I had just returned from dropping my child off at school on foot. And as I was walking down a very busy boulevard, I encountered a man standing on the side of the street with his hands cupped in front of him, but he was looking around into the trees around him. And it was such strange behavior. I had to stop and ask what was going on. And he lowered his hands to reveal a fuzzy little baby blue jay crouched in them. It's little black eyes glittering up at us, very calm, interestingly. And he said, I saw this little baby bird out in the road and I had to go and get it, but I have to go to work. I don't know what to do. And I said, well,
当时正是交通高峰期，一个繁忙的早晨，我刚步行把孩子送到学校回来。当我走一条非常繁忙的大道时，我遇到一个男子站在路边，双手捧在胸前，但他正环顾四周的树木。这种行为太奇怪了，我不得不停下来问发生了什么事。他放低双手，露出一只蜷缩在他手中的毛茸茸的蓝色松鸦小幼鸟。它黑溜溜的小眼睛闪闪发光地看着我们，非常有趣的是，它显得非常平静。他说：“我在路边看到了这只小幼鸟，我不得不去把它抓起来，但我得去上班，我不知道该怎么办。”我说：“好吧，
I'll take over. And so he dumped the little bird into my hands and I took over scanning the trees around me looking to see if there were any parents nearby that I could leave the baby with and there was just nothing. And so I couldn't possibly leave it there. And so I luckily was right next to a local vet and I wandered in with a bird hoping dimly that maybe they would be able to help with the bird. All they could do was give me a box to put it in. And so I put the little baby bird in a box. I walked home with it, called my local animal rescue center and they said they would be
我来接手。”于是他把小鸟倒进我手里，我接手后开始扫描周围的树木，看是否有任何可以把幼鸟托付给的附近亲鸟，但什么都没有。所以我绝对不能把它留在那里。幸运的是，我当时就在一家当地的兽医诊所旁边，我带着这只鸟晃悠进去，隐约希望他们能帮帮这只鸟。他们唯一能做的就是给我一个装它的盒子。于是我把小鸟放进盒子里，带着它走回家，给当地的动物救援中心打电话，他们说他们会
happy to take the baby bird in. And so I took about an hour out of my morning and dropped the baby bird off at a little wildlife center. Now this wasn't sort of a dramatic act of altruism, you know, you were not giving up a kidney, you were not sort of putting your own life in danger, but it is actually when you step back and look at it, it's kind of extraordinary, which is that, you know, the blue jay is not even your species. This is not a creature that belongs to your species, and yet you are willing to take time and effort to protect its well-being.
很乐意接收这只小幼鸟。于是我花了一个早晨大约一个小时的时间，把小鸟送到了一个小型野生动物中心。这并非什么戏剧性的利他行为，你知道的，你没有捐出一个肾，你也没有将自己的生命置于危险之中，但退一步来看，这其实是一种相当了不起的行为，因为（你知道的）蓝色松鸦甚至不是你的物种。这不是一个属于你物种的生物，然而你却愿意花费时间和精力去保护它的福祉。
Absolutely, and this really was a very good example of alloparental care when I look back on it. I was not this baby bird's parent, but I was immediately willing to take over in loco parentis and provide the care it needed to make sure that it was going to survive. And again, it's such a tiny thing in the scheme of things. There's no huge sacrifice on my part.
完全是这样，回想起来，这确实是同种异亲抚育的一个极好的例子。我不是这只小幼鸟的亲生父母，但我立即愿意扮演“代理父母”（in loco parentis）的角色，提供它生存下去所需的照顾。再说，在宏观事物中，这是一件多么微不足道的小事啊。这对我来说并没有做出什么巨大的牺牲。
But looking back, that altruistic impulse that I had to help, regardless of the fact that it was going to cost me, certainly quite a bit of time and effort, really didn't matter to me at all. I just needed to make sure that this little baby was going to be okay. What was your feeling after you dropped off this bird at this Wildlife Rescue Center, Abby? I found that I had grown very attached to it in a short period of time, and I kept track of it. The Wildlife Center very kindly sent me emails about it, that it was being raised with a bunch of other Blue-Jay fledglings that had been dropped off.
但回想起来，我想要提供帮助的那种利他冲动，完全不顾及这会花费我相当多的时间和精力，这对我来说其实根本不重要。我只想确保这个小家伙能够安然无恙。艾比，当你把这只鸟送到这个野生动物救援中心后，你的感受是什么？我发现自己在短时间内对它产生了很深的感情，并且我一直在关注它的情况。野生动物中心非常贴心地给我发电子邮件，告诉我它正和一群被送来的其他蓝色松鸦幼鸟一起被抚养长大。
It had learned to fly, it had learned to feed itself, and then they let me know when it was finally ready to be released back into the wild. One potent factor that stops us from acting selflessly is fear. We worry for our own safety. When we come back, a remarkable story of heroism and what we get wrong about courage. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're talking today to psychologist and neuroscientist, Abigail Marsh, about the science of altruism and generosity. If you have follow-up questions, comments, or stories about altruism and generosity
它已经学会了飞翔，学会了自己觅食，然后他们通知我它终于准备好被放归大自然了。阻止我们采取无私行动的一个强有力的因素是恐惧。我们担心我们自己的安全。当我们回来时，将为您讲述一个关于英雄主义的非凡故事，以及我们对勇敢的错误认知。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。今天我们正在与心理学家和神经科学家阿比盖尔·马什探讨利他主义和慷慨的科学。如果您有关于利他主义和慷慨的后续问题、评论或故事，
that you'd be comfortable sharing with a hidden brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hidden brain dot org. Use the subject line generosity. Psychologist and neuroscientist Abigail Marsh has spent years studying selfishness and selflessness. She has found that one of the most powerful barriers to offering assistance to others in distress is fear. Abby, in 2012, when he was mayor of Newark, New Jersey, the politician Cory Booker carried out a remarkable act of heroism. Can you set the scene for me and describe what happened?
并愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享，请在您的手机上录制语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件至ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题词：慷慨。心理学家和神经科学家阿比盖尔·马什花了好几年时间研究自私与无私。她发现，阻碍向陷入困境的人提供援助的最强大障碍之一就是恐惧。艾比，在2012年，当科里·布克担任新泽西州纽瓦克市市长时，这位政治家实施了一次非凡的英雄主义壮举。你能为我还原当时的场景并描述发生了什么吗？
Absolutely. It's an incredible story. So Booker was coming home one night with a couple of members of his security detail. And when they got close to his house, they discovered that the home of the neighbor next door was on fire. Smoke was pouring through the windows.
当然。这是一个不可思议的故事。当时布克和一个安保小组的成员在一个夜晚回家。当他们靠近他的房子时，他们发现隔壁邻居的房子着火了。浓烟正从窗户喷涌而出。
And Booker's neighbor, whose name was Jacqueline Williams, was outside in the yard screaming that her daughter was still trapped inside the house on the second floor. And what Booker said later is exactly what many, many heroic rescuers say is that he acted without even thinking. He jumped out of the car, he ran across the yard and started to run into the house with one of his security detail running right behind him.
布克的邻居，名叫杰奎琳·威廉姆斯（Jacqueline Williams），当时正在院子里尖叫，说她的女儿还被困在二楼的房子里。布克后来所说的话，正是许多许多英雄救援人员所说的话：他在没有思考的情况下就行动了。他跳出车子，跑过院子，冲进屋里，其中一名安保人员紧随其后。
And of course, once he got into the door, he discovered that the air was full of smoke and he could see hardly anything as he's gasping and choking his way up to the kitchen on the second floor. Once they got there, they discovered that there were flames everywhere going up the walls, across the ceiling. They could hear little explosions and the security detail whose name was Rodriguez was like, I've had enough. We're not going any further. He tried to get Booker to leave the house without rescuing his neighbor's daughter. Booker refused. They wrestled for a little bit. Booker said, you
当然，一旦他进门，他就发现空气中充满了浓烟，他几乎什么也看不见，喘着粗气并剧烈咳嗽着向二楼的厨房摸索上去。一旦他们到了那里，他们发现到处都是火焰，顺着墙壁向上蔓延，横跨天花板。他们能听到小型的爆炸声，那个名叫罗德里格斯（Rodriguez）的安保人员当时说：“我受够了。我们不能再前进了。”他试图让布克离开房子，而不是去营救邻居的女儿。布克拒绝了。他们扭打了一会儿。布克说，
know, you have to let me go in. If I don't go in, she's going to die. And so the detective said, okay. And Booker plunged into the house, fought his way through the smoke into the bedroom where his neighbor's daughter was barely conscious, flung her over his shoulder and staggered back through the kitchen, which was engulfed in flames at this point. Burning embers are raining down on him, and he finally makes it back out of the house and collapses into the yard, where he was taken by ambulance to the hospital with injuries from smoke inhalation and second degree burns to his hands.
“你知道的，你得让我进去。如果我不进去，她会死的。”于是侦探说：“好吧。”布克冲进房子，在浓烟中拼死冲进卧室，他邻居的女儿当时已经不省人事了，他把她扛在肩上，跌跌撞撞地穿过此时已被大火吞没的厨房。燃烧的余烬像雨点般落在他身上，他终于逃出了房子，瘫倒在院子里，随后因吸入浓烟受伤以及双手二度烧伤而被救护车送往医院。
So when the story explodes in the media and it takes off on social media, a lot of people describe what Booker did as almost the actions of a superhero. Can you talk about that? That people talked about him as if he was a superhero? Absolutely. So I think when we look at acts of courage like this from the outside, it's not obvious to us how the person is feeling on the inside. And we often assume, well, I would be too afraid to do that, that person must not have been afraid at all. And some of the quotes on social media were really hilarious in painting Booker as this impervious to fear
因此，当这个故事在媒体上炸开锅并在社交媒体上疯传时，许多人将布克的行为形容为几乎是超级英雄的行动。你能谈谈这个吗？人们谈论他就好像他是一个超级英雄一样？完全是的。所以我想，当我们从外部看待这种勇敢行为时，我们并不清楚当事人内心感受如何。我们经常假设：“噢，我会因为太害怕而不敢那样做，那个人一定一点也不害怕。”社交媒体上的一些言论非常滑稽，把布克描绘成一个对恐惧免疫的
superhero. One of my favorite was when Chuck Norris, the action hero, has nightmares, Cory Booker turns on the lights and sits with him until he falls asleep. One of my other favorites is somebody who posted, Cory Booker isn't afraid of the dark. The dark is afraid of Cory Booker. I'd like to play a clip of Cory Booker appearing on the program CBS This Morning, talking about what the experience was actually like for him.
超级英雄。我最喜欢的其中一条是：“当动作英雄查克·诺里斯（Chuck Norris）做噩梦时，科里·布克会打开灯陪着他，直到他睡着。”我另一个最喜欢的是有人发帖说：“科里·布克不怕黑暗，黑暗害怕科里·布克。”我想播放一段科里·布克出现在哥伦比亚广播公司《CBS今晨》节目中的片段，谈谈对他的实际体验到底是怎样的。
It was very different for me when I was, had left him, when he finally got him to let go of me, went through the flames. It is a very, very scary thing. And I was, had left him, when he finally got him to let go of me, went through the flames. It is a very, very scary thing. And I'd like to say that at that point, I was feeling so courageous, but honestly it was terrifying. So we think that people who act bravely feel no fear, Abby, but that doesn't seem to be the case at all
当我离开他时，情况对我来说非常不同，当我终于让他放开我、穿过火焰时。这是一件非常、非常可怕的事情。我想说，在那一刻，我感觉自己是如此勇敢，但老实说，那是极其可怕的。所以我们认为那些表现勇敢的人不会感到恐惧，艾比，但这在科里·布克身上似乎完全不是那么回事。
with Cory Booker. Absolutely not. In every interview he gave after what happened, he was very honest about how terrified he had been throughout. And I think it's really important to distinguish between people who are truly fearless, which is really a form of recklessness to not even log the danger that you're confronting in a scary situation, and people who are brave. And people who are brave are people who recognize that there's a danger to themselves, who might
绝对不是。在事后他接受的所有采访中，他都非常诚实地表达了自己在整个过程中是多么恐惧。我认为区分真正无所畏惧的人（这实际上是一种鲁莽的表现，在可怕的情境中甚至无法意识到你所面对的危险）和勇敢的人是非常重要的。勇敢的人是那些认识到自己正处于危险之中、
feel quite frightened on their own behalf, but who recognize that there's a danger to themselves, who might feel quite frightened on their own behalf, but who realize that there's something more important than their fear for themselves and who act anyways in the face of their fear. And that's real virtue. And I hope that people can appreciate just how often real heroes are very frightened and they're acting anyhow. and real heroes are very frightened and they're acting anyhow. I mean, this was true for many of your kidney donors as well. I mean, it wasn't that they lacked trepidation about going through major surgery.
可能会为自己感到相当害怕，但却意识到有比他们对自身的恐惧更重要的事情、并且在恐惧面前依然采取行动的人。这才是真正的美德。我希望人们能够体会到，真正的英雄往往是非常害怕的，但他们依然会采取行动。我的意思是，这对于你的许多肾脏捐献者来说也是一样的。我的意思是，他们并不是对经历大手术毫无畏惧。
It wasn't something that they brushed off is basically trivial. Absolutely. I've worked with many altruistic kidney donors who have true phobias of needles. One 19-year-old altruistic kidney donor that we worked with would often faint when she got blood draws. She was so frightened of needles. And of course, you get a lot of blood draws in the process of donating a kidney. But because she cared much more about the welfare of the person whose life she would be saving than she cared about her own discomfort or fear in the moment, it just didn't bother her that she would have to feel a
这也不是他们可以轻描淡写地视为微不足道的事情。绝对是的。我曾与许多患有真正针头恐惧症的利他肾脏捐献者合作过。我们合作过的一位19岁利他肾脏捐献者在抽血时经常会晕倒。她太害怕针头了。当然，在捐献肾脏的过程中，你需要抽很多血。但因为她比起自己当下的不适或恐惧，更加关心那个将因她而获救的人的福祉，所以她要承受一点恐惧和不适来帮忙这件事，对她来说根本不算什么。
little fear and discomfort in order to help. So are you saying that one of the first steps toward dealing with our fear is in some ways pushing back on the idea that we shouldn't feel fear or cannot act if we feel fear? That's exactly right. Emotion is, I think, a good source of information, but it's a very bad boss. We should never assume that our emotions are the true source of truth. And oftentimes our fear is telling us to do things that aren't consistent with our values, right? If you really do want to help somebody, it's normal to feel afraid
所以你是说，应对恐惧的第一步，在某种程度上就是打破“我们不应该感到恐惧”或“如果我们感到恐惧就无法采取行动”的想法？完全正确。我认为情绪是一个很好的信息来源，但它是一个非常糟糕的老板。我们绝不能假设我们的情绪就是事实的真实来源。而且很多时候，我们的恐惧在怂恿我们做那些不符合我们价值观的事情，对吧？如果你真的想帮助别人，当你明知自己可能会受伤、可能会经历疼痛或不适时，感到害怕是正常的。而真正的英雄会在这种感觉面前、不顾这种感觉而采取行动。所以，存在这样一个领域：大量的人将另一个生物的福祉置于自己之上。花点时间谈谈父母在孩子处于危险时表现出的勇气，以及这可能教会我们关于恐惧、爱与勇气之间的关系。我想我有过一点真正的英雄和利他主义者所体验到的感受的滋味，那是在一个夏日的下午，当时我的其中一个孩子还小，
when you know that there's a risk that you might be injured or that you might experience pain or discomfort. And truly heroic people act in the face of that feeling and despite that feeling. So, there is a domain where large numbers of people put the well-being of another creature above themselves. Talk a moment about the courage that parents show when their children are in danger and what this might teach us about the relationship between fear and love and courage. I think I had just a little taste of what some true heroes and altruists experience one summer afternoon when one of my kids was younger
刚学会游泳，在邻居的游泳池里戏水，结果被一个像救生圈形状的泳池玩具卡在了下面，又不会踩水。于是她开始向水面以下沉去。就在她的小脸蛋没入水面之前，她尖叫道：
and had just learned how to swim and was paddling in a neighbor's pool and got trapped under like a life preserver shaped pool toy and didn't know how to tread water. And so she started to sink underneath the surface of the water. And just before her little face went under, she screamed,
“妈妈，救我！”这个声音像闪电一样刺穿了我的大脑。我真的在没有思考的情况下采取了行动。我穿着衣服、口袋里揣着手机就跳进了泳池，甚至没有花一秒钟去思考我在做什么。我把她从救生圈下拉了出来，把她带回了岸上。
Mommy, help me! In this voice that like zapped like lightning through my brain. And I truly acted without thinking. I was in the pool, fully clothed, phone in my pocket, before I had thought even just for a second about what I was doing. And I pulled her out from under the life preserver and I got her back on the shore. And there was no thought whatsoever involved. I was going to get in that pool and I was going to help her no matter what. The welfare of my daughter, her life, her safety is so overwhelming that I can imagine
这其中根本没有经过任何思考。我要跳进那个泳池，不管怎样我都要去救她。我女儿的福祉、她的生命、她的安全是如此压倒一切，以至于我可以想象，当时的情况对我来说可能要危险得多，而我会做出完全相同的反应，我想大多数父母也会如此。所以我们之前讨论过这样一个观点：人类天生就是同种异亲抚育者，我们不仅对照顾自己的孩子感兴趣，也对照顾别人的孩子感兴趣。我想知道，鉴于你关于这种助人冲动可能根植于我们照顾幼儿的能力的研究，
the situation could have been much more dangerous for me and I would have acted exactly the same way and I think most parents would. So we talked earlier about this idea that humans are designed to be alloparents, that we are interested in caring not just for our own children but for other people's children. And I'm wondering, given your research on how this urge to help may be rooted in our capacity to provide care to young
在某种程度上，增加我们利他主义的一种方法就是扩大同种异亲抚育的圈子。换句话说，像对待我们自己的孩子一样去思考其他人、陌生人。绝对是的。我的意思是，这有助于提醒我们：外面的每个人曾经都曾是个孩子，我们中的许多人在成年后都需要其他人的帮助和协助，就像我们在年幼时所有人做的那样。
children, one way to increase our altruism in some ways is to expand the circle of alloparenting. In other words, to think about people, other people, strangers, the way we might think about our own children. Absolutely. I mean, it helps to remember that everybody out there once was a child, that many of us need help and assistance from other people as adults, just the way that we all do when we're younger.
这不是一种你长大了就能完全摆脱的需求。我想，如果我们能把在考虑儿童需求时采用的那种心态，同样应用到思考其他人的需求上，我们就会受到极大的启发去提供帮助。你说过，克服阻碍我们帮助他人的恐惧的方法之一，就是让自己暴露在可怕的经历中。在可怕的情境中克服恐惧的能力
It's not something you ever completely grow out of. And I think if we can adopt the same mentality when thinking of the needs of other people that we would when we're thinking about the needs of children, we would be much more inspired to help. You say that one way we might overcome the fear that could hold us back from helping others is to expose ourselves to scary experiences. The capacity to work through your fear
是一种可以培养的能力。有相当充分的证据表明，当人们经历过足够多的危险情境、能够管理自己的恐惧并且对“自己能够应对”有良好感知时，他们在危险情境中做出勇敢行为的能力就更强，对吧？
in frightening situations is a capacity that can be developed. And there's pretty good evidence to suggest that people are more capable of acting bravely in dangerous situations when they've been in enough dangerous situations to be able to manage their fear and to have a good sense that they can handle it, right?
没有什么比通过经验学习更能说明问题的了，比如：我曾处于危险情境中，我感到害怕，但一切都好。我应对并挺了过去，而且我做了我想做的事。因此，我们越是让自己暴露在那些给我们带来恐惧感但最终安然无恙的挑战和风险中，我们就越有可能在危险情境（包括当其他人处于危险之中的情境）中表现出我们期望的行为。我认为非常有趣的是，好莱坞的动作英雄演员们经常
There's nothing like learning by experience that I've been in a dangerous situation, I felt scared, but it was okay. I managed and I got through to the other side and I did what I wanted to do. And so the more that we can expose ourselves to challenges and risks that give us the experience of feeling afraid and it being okay in the end, the more likely we are to act the way we want to in dangerous situations, including those when somebody else is in danger. I think it's really quite interesting how often Hollywood actors who are action heroes
挺身而出，把其他人从危险中解救出来。丹尼·特乔（Danny Trejo）就是一个例子，还有演员杰米·福克斯（Jamie Foxx）、汤姆·克鲁斯（Tom Cruise）、凯特·温丝莱特（Kate Winslet）和本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇（Benedict Cumberbatch）。有大量的名人都曾帮助过现实生活中身处危险的人。我认为这并非0%的概率纯属巧合，原因可能是他们以前曾多次在危险情境中扮演过英雄角色。
leap in to help other people from danger with Danny Trejo being one example, but the actors Jamie Foxx and Tom Cruise and Kate Winslet and Benedict Cumberbatch. Like there's an enormous number of celebrities who have helped real life people in danger. And I think it's not a 0% chance that that's because they have acted out, acting heroically in dangerous situations many times previously.
我的意思是，在某种程度上，我听到你所说的是：变得更具利他主义的方法就是去变得更具利他主义。事情其实就是这么简单。很多时候，改变行为发生在改变思维方式之前。人们常常认为，在改变行为方式之前，我需要先改变对某种情况的感受，而事实往往恰恰相反。实际上，你只需要开始做你想做的事，你的大脑、你的心智、你的情绪稍后就会跟上。
I mean, in some ways what I hear you saying is that the way to become more altruistic is to be more altruistic. It's really as simple as that. Oftentimes, changing your behavior comes before changing your mindset. People often think, well, I need to change the way I feel about a situation before I change the way I act, when often it's the reverse. Really you have to just start doing the thing you want to do, and your brain, your mind, your mood will catch up later.
所以，变得更具利他主义的最佳方法就是直接开始。从小事做起。从让你觉得舒适的小事做起。从轻松的小事做起。但利他主义最棒的地方在于，它感觉真的很棒。对大多数人来说，帮助他人具有内在的奖赏意义，这出于很多原因。这是因为当我们做出了符合我们价值观的事情时，我们会感到自豪。当我们采取行动应对充满挑战的情境时，我们会感受到一种自我效能感。
And so the best way to become more altruistic is to just start. And start small. Start as small as is comfortable. Start as small as is easy. But the best thing about altruism is that it feels really good. For most people, it's intrinsically rewarding to help other people, and this is true for a lot of reasons. It's because we feel proud when we've done something consistent with our values. We feel a sense of self-efficacy when we've acted to take on a situation that was challenging.
当然，我们也会感受到因为让别人感觉良好而获得的替代性奖励。正因为利他主义具有强化作用，我们做得越多，我们就越想去做。所以当许多人面对挑战，特别是像饥饿、疾病或战争这样的大问题时（你知道的），他们会对自己说：一个人能做什么来阻止这一切？一个人怎么能产生影响呢？艾比，你对他们有什么建议？当我们面对世界上所有的苦难和挑战时，要感到
And of course, we feel the vicarious reward we get for making somebody else feel good. And because altruism is reinforcing, the more we do it, the more we'll want to do it. So when many people confront a challenge, especially a big problem like starvation or disease or war, you know, they tell themselves what can one person do to stop this? How can one person make a difference? What advice would you have for them, Abby? It is really hard when we confront all the suffering and challenges in the world to feel
有动力去行动真的很困难，因为这些问题看起来太大了。而且我有充分的理由相信，我们的大脑确实没有进化到能够处理我们在此时此刻能够获取知识的这种范围和规模的挑战。所以我觉得，专注于你能解决的那类挑战真的很重要。就像制定任何其他计划一样，对吧？如果你想以符合你价值观的方式行事，你就要考虑我可以采取的下一步行动是什么，以使我的行为更贴近我的价值观。所以它确实
motivated to act because these problems can seem so big. And I think there's very good reason to believe that our brains really didn't evolve to handle challenges at the kind of scope and scale that we have access to knowledge about at this moment in time. And so I think it's really important to focus on the kinds of challenges that you can solve. Just like forming any other plan, right? If you want to act in ways that match your values, you think of what's the next step I can take to bring my actions closer to alignment with my values. And so it's really
促使我们采取行动，因为这些问题看起来太大了。我认为有充分的理由相信，我们的大脑在进化时，并未准备好应对我们目前所能接触到的这种范围和规模的挑战。因此，我认为专注于那些你能解决的挑战真的很重要。就像制定任何其他计划一样，对吧？如果你想以符合你价值观的方式行事，你就要思考我能采取的下一步是什么，以使我的行动更符合我的价值观。所以这真的很
important to just look around the world around you, the physical world that you inhabit, and take notice of situations where there's somebody who is in need. This could be local charities where your actions really could make a difference. It could be strangers that you pass by in the street who if you're paying, you may see that they have a need, that they are in trouble in ways that you could help. So you told me the story about how you rescued your daughter from your neighbor's swimming pool. Now, presumably, you're a decent swimmer. You didn't really fear for your life
重要的是环顾你周围的世界，也就是你所处的物理世界，并注意那些有人需要帮助的情况。这可能是当地的慈善机构，你的行动确实能产生影响。这可能是你在街上擦肩而过的陌生人，如果你留心的话，你可能会发现他们有需求，他们正陷入你可以提供帮助的困境。所以你给我讲了这样一个故事：你从邻居的游泳池里救出了你的女儿。现在，据我推测，你是个不错的游泳健将。你并没有真正为自己的生命感到担忧
when you jumped in the pool. But some years ago, I understand that you were on a local ski hill, and something happened where you had to rescue someone. And in this case, perhaps, you were not as good and confident a skier as you might have been a swimmer. Tell me the story of what happened. Yes, this was more recently on a local ski hill, and one of my kids decided that they wanted to ski
当你跳进泳池的时候。但据我了解，几年前你在当地的一个滑雪场，发生了一些事情，你不得不去救某人。在这种情况下，也许你滑雪并不像游泳那样擅长和自信。给我讲讲发生了什么事吧。是的，这是最近在当地的一个滑雪场发生的，我的一个孩子决定要去滑雪
in the terrain park area of the ski hill. And I am deeply afraid of terrain parks. I am a fine skier, but I definitely do not like going very fast, and I do not like doing jumps. But I waited at the top of the terrain park while one of my kids decided to go down the terrain and lo and behold, they were not well enough equipped for this terrain park and ended up, you know, juttering over a bunch of bumps and then disappearing from sight,
在滑雪场的地形公园区域。而我非常害怕地形公园。我滑雪技术还行，但我绝对不喜欢滑得太快，也不喜欢做跳跃动作。但我在地形公园的顶部等待，当时我的一个孩子决定滑下这个地形，果不其然，他们对这个地形公园的装备不够熟练，结果呢，在一堆颠簸中磕磕绊绊，然后消失在视线之外，
flying in the air and disappearing from sight. And I panicked because I knew that they could have fallen in the spot that they were and hurt themselves really badly. And before I knew it, I found myself flying could have fallen in the spot that they were and hurt themselves really badly and before I knew What I found myself flying through this terrain park avoiding as best I could they're really big jumps much faster than I'm normally comfortable skiing To get to my child and make sure that she was okay now She had smashed her face pretty badly at the bottom of the series of jumps She'd been over and blood was pouring down her face and she wasn't very happy in the moment.
在空中飞驰并消失在视线之外。我惊慌失措，因为我知道他们可能会在他们所在的地方摔倒，并且受很重的伤。在我还没反应过来之前，我发现自己飞驰而过，可能在他们所在的地方摔倒并受了重伤，在我还没意识到的时候，我发现自己穿过了这个地形公园，尽我所能避开那些非常大的跳跃，以比我平时习惯的滑雪速度快得多的速度，去到我的孩子身边并确保她没事。现在，她在这一系列跳跃的底部脸部摔得很重。她翻了个身，满脸是血，当时她很不高兴。
Luckily she was okay. But I do remember thinking afterward, that is the fastest I have skied in a very long time. But I just, you know, as so many people I've talked to over the years have told me, you don't think of yourself in the moment. You just think of what the other person needs and about trying to help. Abigail Marsh is a psychologist and neuroscientist at Georgetown University. She's the author of The Fear Factor, how one Emotion Connects Altruists, Psychopaths,
幸运的是她没事。但我确实记得事后想过，那是我很长一段时间以来滑得最快的一次。但我只是，正如我这些年来交谈过的许多人所告诉我的那样，你在当时不会考虑自己。你只会考虑另一个人需要什么，并努力提供帮助。阿比盖尔·马什是乔治敦大学的心理学家和神经科学家。她是《恐惧因子：一种情绪如何连接利他主义者、精神病态者》一书的作者，
and Everyone in Between. Abby, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a real pleasure. Do you have follow-up questions, comments, or stories about altruism and generosity? If you'd be comfortable sharing your thoughts with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to
以及介于两者之间的所有人。阿比，非常感谢你今天来到《隐形大脑》。这真是一种荣幸。你对利他主义和慷慨有什么后续问题、评论或故事吗？如果你乐意与《隐形大脑》的听众分享你的想法，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并将其发送电子邮件至
us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line generosity. That email address again is ideas at hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirrell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung heroes today are a group of superfans I met recently in Portland during a stop on Hiddenbrain's live tour. Forrest Ingram, Leif Mohanderson, Dawn Schneider, Catherine Cournay, and Amy and Dave Valente, it was wonderful to meet you and have the opportunity to share a meal with you.
我们，邮箱是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。主题请写“慷慨”。再次重申那个电子邮件地址是 ideas@hiddenBrain Media。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐形大脑》的执行主编。我们今天的无名英雄是一群超级粉丝，我最近在《隐形大脑》巡回演出的波特兰站偶然遇到了他们。福雷斯特·英格拉姆、莱夫·莫汉德森、道恩·施耐德、凯瑟琳·库尔奈，以及艾米和戴夫·瓦伦特，很高兴能与你们见面并有机会与你们共进晚餐。
Thank you for your support of Hiddenbrain and the work that we do. We are truly grateful. Upcoming stops on what we're calling the Perceptions Tour include Phoenix, Baltimore, Washington DC and Los Angeles. For more information and to purchase tickets to those shows, go to hiddenbrain.org slash tour. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢你们对《隐形大脑》以及我们所做工作的支持。我们对此深表感激。我们称之为“感知之旅”的下一站包括菲尼克斯、巴尔的摩、华盛顿特区和洛杉矶。有关更多信息并购买这些演出的门票，请访问 hiddenbrain.org/tour。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。